right now judge Mazon a Texas federal
judge is reviewing whether or not to
grant a temporary restraining order for
Elliott judgments Clerk's office has
said that we'll get a decision by Friday
if it's granted that would restrain the
NFL from imposing the sixth game
suspension for a limited period of time
probably about two weeks then there
would be an additional hearing to see if
it can be extended and if he declines to
invoke the temporary restraining order
that would be a huge defeat for Elliott
it would be hard for him to come back
from that let's rewind this a little bit
then in the fact that Ezekiel Elliott
can play this week it is very confusing
to a lot of people how a suspension can
get upheld and then the NFL agrees to
the fact that he gets to play in week
one why would the NFL do that
well the NFL has issued a statement that
that basically says because the decision
of Harold Henderson wasn't made before
Elliott went to court yesterday
it's essential for fairness that Elliott
not be suspended for this first week's
games it's not it's certainly not
required I think with the end I think
what's going on here is the NFL's
mindful of appearance and mindful of the
fact that they want to seem fair and
reasonable right as judgment is deciding
whether or not to rule in favor of
Elliott or the NFL I think timing
matters here if this case wasn't in
court I don't know if the NFL would be
so generous I think frankly that the
NFL's thinking about impact on the judge
and they're also thinking about other
judges could get involved in this
litigation the NFL is trying to move it
to New York even if it stays in Texas
there could be appellate judges so the
NFL is certainly looking at the optics
of what they do in terms of how judges
are reacting to it before we get to the
New York of it all so you're saying that
if if Harold Henderson had made his
ruling before that hearing started the
NFL might not have offered Ezekiel
Elliott the the week one helmet possibly
because the argument would be that
Elliott wouldn't have been prejudiced in
that hearing because he didn't know what
Henderson was gonna do if he knew then
there would have been less harm on
Elliott going into that hearing well why
wouldn't
New York Giants be hopping mad right now
Michael and the fact that not only is
Ezekiel Elliott gonna suit up against
them but the league says to a judge it's
too late in the week to just sit here
and tell him he can't play week one when
Odell Beckham jr. was told on a
Wednesday once upon a time he couldn't
play in a game yeah it's hard to
reconcile those two things and I think
the Giants would have a valid argument
in terms of logic the NFL would probably
respond saying this is a little bit
different because it's now in the legal
system and secondarily it's the league's
discretion the league doesn't really
have to be consistent by rule it would
be better if they were but they're not
obligated to the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show app
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show